A very good rapid-descent technique, especially if you've drifted into a cloud.
For the B-stall, we pull all the B-risers and push the wing together via the B-riser group.
That stalls the wing — strictly speaking, you collapse it into a flat shape,
the airflow stalls, and you sink down in a so-called parachutal descent.
But even if you pulled it open across the full span,
you'd still simply be collapsing it via the B-riser group.
Sink rate is around 7 metres per second.
Which is pretty good.
And in the B-stall, you have practically no physical strain.
It's a bit demanding at the start, but then holding it actually works quite well.
But there's no physical strain.
And that's why you can do this for a longer period of time.
Otherwise it'd just be too much load on the body.
Anyone who wants to do it as an A-licence pilot, sure, you can.
But it's not an effective manoeuvre for everyone,
just so you can get out of trouble if needed.
For the B-stall, you keep the brake just loosely on the strap in your hand.
Now, so that the B-risers don't accidentally slip out of our hands,
we spread our fingers and put them between the B-lines,
above the line locks, and grab them symmetrically,
nicely above the line locks.
That way the B-risers can't accidentally escape from us.
Now it's important that we do a slow,
but powerful pull-down on them.
And we hold that for at least four to five seconds.
Only on my command, hands up.
So, hands go up for the exit.
Now I'll also show you why the hands need to go up.
If we just let the B-risers snap back from this position,
we might end up additionally on the brakes.
That would be a problem when we let the B-stall go again.
The wing actually wants to surge forward,
but it's still for a moment in parachutal flight,
and if I then go on the brakes,
I might actually need to put my hands all the way up,
to push it back into normal flight.
And that's why we never want to let the risers just snap back,
we actively guide them up.
That's how you cleanly come out of the B-stall.
On the entry, we close the B-risers together.
And this brake-hold position is so important.
And also don't let them snap back
while we're surging forward.
Because then the wing from that position would start to fly again and could accelerate quite well
and possibly even accelerate too hard.
And that's why it's important to keep the B-stall, or the B-risers,
down for at least 3 to 4 seconds.
So pull down, keep down, so that we can swing back under the wing
again.
Then once we've swung back under, calmly release.